lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
ver una serie de vectores que están
dibujados en su forma estándar es decir
sus puntos iniciales están en el origen
o podemos decir que sus colas están en
el origen y vamos a ver si podemos
encontrar dados estos vectores sus
ángulos positivos a partir del lado
positivo del eje x y como siempre te
encargó que pausa el vídeo e intentes
encontrar el valor de estos ángulos por
tu cuenta
nosotros lo resolveremos usando como
unidad de medida los grados bien el
primero que resolveremos es este vector
y observa que si lo escribimos
utilizando vectores canónicos lo cual es
muy útil para los ingenieros y a veces
se les dice notación ingenieril tenemos
que este vector 1 es igual a 3 veces y
es decir el vector unitario en la
dirección horizontal más cuatro veces el
vector j
es decir el vector unitario en la direc
vertical o también podemos representar
al mismo vector y de la siguiente manera
podemos decir que su componente x es 3 y
su componente james es 4 y lo puedes ver
aquí tú puedes empezar en el origen y
moverte una dos tres unidades en
dirección horizontal y una dos tres
cuatro unidades en dirección vertical
ahora bien para averiguar el valor de
este ángulo theta hay varias formas de
hacerlo una de ellas es construir un
triángulo rectángulo al menos en este
caso particular podemos decir que el
triángulo rectángulo se va a ver de la
siguiente manera este lado este lado va
a tener una longitud de tres unidades
porque es lo que caminamos en el eje x
la coordenada en x es 3
entonces este lado va a medir 3 unidades
mientras que subimos hasta una altura de
4 por lo tanto este lado de mi triángulo
rectángulo va a tener una
longitud de 4 dicho de otra manera mi
coordenada en yes 4 y por lo tanto la
longitud de este lado va a hacer 4 y
bueno sabemos por las definiciones de
las funciones trigonométricas del zocato
am cuál es la función trigonométricas
que involucran al lado opuesto y al lado
adyacente de este ángulo teta y bueno la
respuesta es la tangente recuerda el
zocato am sabemos que la tangente la
tangente de este ángulo de damm va a ser
igual a la longitud del lado opuesto que
es 4 a la longitud del lado opuesto que
es 4 entre la longitud del lado
adyacente lo cual sabemos que es 3 y si
queremos resolver para este ángulo teta
entonces podemos tomar la función
inversa de la tangente que la de notamos
como tangente a la menos 1 tangente a la
menos 1 estamos hablando de la función
inversa de la tangente o también algunas
veces se le conoce
con el nombre de arco tangente de bueno
esta cantidad de cuatro tercios así que
déjame ponerlo de cuatro tercios y si
queremos resolver esto entonces déjame
traer por acá mi calculadora y me tomo
cuatro tercios 4 entre 3 esto es de 1
que 1.33 y a esto le voy a calcular la
función inversa de la tangente y para
eso voy a apretar este botón que tengo
aquí y voy a aplicar la función inversa
de la tangente justo así y con esto
obtengo 53.1 aproximadamente si lo
redondeo me queda como 53.1 grados así
que déjame escribirlo por aquí voy a
decir que este ángulo que estoy buscando
theta va a tener y déjame ponerlo con
este color va a tener como medida
aproximadamente
53.1 grados lo cual se ve bastante bien
porque observa que es un poco más de 45
grados este vector está a un poco más de
45 grados digo no lo dibujes súper
preciso pero se ve como un poco más de
45 grados así que parece que esto es
correcto ahora otra cosa que puedes
decir es hey mira 4 es la componente y y
3 es la componente x así que tal vez la
tangente del ángulo que estoy buscando
siempre sea la componente y entre la
componente x y esto en efecto es el caso
todo esto viene de la definición las
funciones trigonométricas del círculo
unitario donde puedes ver que si tienes
un círculo unitario es más déjame
dibujarlo lo voy a poner por aquí y no
va a ser muy preciso pero te va a ayudar
a entender todo lo que te estoy
explicando
imagínate que por aquí me tomo a un
círculo unitario va a ser algo más o
menos
así voy a suponer que este es mi círculo
unitario bien y después dibujamos por
aquí en una línea perfecto voy a hacer
esta línea de aquí yo sé que estamos
hablando de vectores pero es exactamente
lo mismo aquí tengo esta línea y
entonces te fijas en el ángulo que se
forma a partir del eje x y te preguntas
por su tangente esta va a ser déjame
anotarlo la tangente de este ángulo
sería exactamente igual que la
coordenada en jeff de este punto donde
detectamos al círculo unitario la
coordenada en en donde interceptamos al
círculo unitario entre la coordenada en
x así que puedes imaginar que si aquí
mismo hacemos un círculo unitario lo voy
a dibujar más o menos así por aquí tengo
un círculo unitario y te fijas en la
razón entre la coordenada ayer y la
coordenada x de este punto que
intersecta el 'ciclón' etario esa razón
va a ser exactamente la misma que la
razón entre 4 y 3 va a ser lo mismo que
cuatro tercios o un entero un tercio así
que de cualquier manera siempre que
pienses en un vector la tangente de este
ángulo que estamos buscando es decir de
este ángulo que se forma a partir del
lado positivo del eje x va a ser igual a
la componente y entre la componente x
así que es muy agradable cuando obtienes
un resultado como éste
bien pues usemos esto mismo para
encontrar el siguiente ángulo este que
tengo aquí bueno pues entonces podemos
decir que la tangente de este ángulo la
tangente de este ángulo teta va a ser
igual a quien bueno a la componente ya
que la voy a poner con este color a la
componente ye entre la componente x que
la voy a poner con este color
así que 6 entre 5 y este signo negativo
lo voy a poner aquí o podemos decir que
te da va a ser igual a la función
inversa de la tangente
quintos negativos sin embargo voy a
poner un signo de interrogación aquí
porque estoy casi seguro que no nos
vamos a sentir felices con la respuesta
de esta operación así que hagámoslo a
ver qué obtenemos si sacamos nuestra
calculadora de nuevo la tengo por aquí y
me tomo
entre 5 ya esto le cambió el signo y
después le aplicó la función tangente
inversa llego a un ángulo de menos 50.2
si lo redondeamos así que déjame notarlo
en este caso theta es aproximadamente
menos 50 punto 2 grados pero porque esto
no se ve bien
bueno pues observa que teta se ve más
grande que 90 grados y menos 50.2 grados
me da un ángulo que bueno realmente está
por acá están más o menos aquí este
ángulo nos está dando otro vector u otra
línea que tiene la misma tangente por
esto creo que es importantísimo
visualizarlo y pensarlo la razón de por
qué obtuvimos este resultado es que la
función inversa de la tangente o el
largo tangente esta función que vemos en
las calculadoras siempre nos da un
ángulo que está entre menos
grados y 90 grados siempre un ángulo que
está aquí por eso mismo siempre nos dará
un ángulo en el primer cuadrante o en el
cuarto cuadrante pero aquí tenemos algo
que está en el segundo cuadrante así que
para estar seguros de que lo estamos
haciendo bien tenemos que hacer el
procedimiento correcto este ángulo nos
da el caso de tener esta línea o este
vector más o menos se vería algo así así
que para encontrar nuestro ángulo de
respuesta el ángulo que buscamos lo que
vamos a hacer es sumar 180 grados a este
ángulo que tengo aquí así que para
obtener el ángulo que nosotros queremos
theta como queremos un ángulo en la otra
dirección entonces éste está va a ser
aproximadamente menos 50 punto 2 grados
a 180 grados
lo cual es no sé vamos a hacerlo en la
calculadora y a esta cantidad le voy a
sumar 180 grados y esto me va a dar
ciento 29.8 redondeado entonces así que
aproximadamente este ángulo que
buscábamos theta va a ser de 120 9.82 y
esto se ve mucho mejor porque tenemos un
ángulo más allá de los 90 grados ahora
otra forma de pensar este mismo problema
es la siguiente si pensamos en el sol
que actúa de los triángulos rectángulos
y si construimos por aquí un triángulo
rectángulo entonces que nos va a quedar
bueno pues sabemos que la altura de ese
triángulo rectángulo va a ser de 6 y
esta longitud va a ser de 6 que es justo
la coordenada en jr déjame notarlo 6
unidades y también sabemos que la
longitud d
en este lado que tengo aquí va a ser de
bueno ten cuidado sabemos que del origen
caminamos 5 unidades hacia la izquierda
eso es menos 5 pero si pensamos en esto
como una longitud entonces hay que
tomarnos el valor absoluto de menos 5 lo
cual nos va a dar 5 es decir la longitud
de la base es de 5 unidades y con esto
podemos averiguar cuánto vale no sé voy
a ponerlo con este color este ángulo que
voy a llamar x y bueno si hablamos de
este ángulo x quien va a ser la tangente
la tangente desde ángulo x bueno pues es
el cateto opuesto entre el cateto
adyacente entonces me va a quedar 6
sobre
sobre este lado sobre 5 o dicho de otra
manera
x va a ser igual a la función inversa de
la tangente de quien de esta cantidad de
6 sobre 5 y cuántos esto vamos a ver
para eso voy a traer de nuevo a mi
calculadora y vamos a hacer esta
operación 6 entre 5 es 1.2 y le sacó la
función inversa de la tangente a esta
cantidad y obtengo claro 50.2
aproximadamente entonces déjame notarlo
x va a ser aproximadamente 50 punto 2
grados que es este valor que tengo aquí
lo cual se ve bastante bien pero
recuerda que lo que queremos encontrar
es el valor de teta queda en este ángulo
que tengo aquí este ángulo que tengo
aquí está este está pero observa que x y
theta son suplementarios entonces
mas x deben de sumar 180 grados y theta
es lo mismo que 180 grados menos x así
que vamos a hacerlo si a esta cantidad
le pongo un signo negativo y después le
sumó 180 grados
creo que ya te parece muy familiar voy a
obtener ciento 29.8 proximadamente lo
cual era exactamente lo que obtuvimos
antes